un nuevo golpe para Donald Trump el ex
presidente de Estados Unidos Fue citado
este viernes por el comité de
representantes para declarar sobre el
ataque del 6 de enero de 2021 al
Capitolio y le pidió proporcionar una
serie de documentos que van desde
comunicaciones personales entre el
republicano y miembros del Congreso
hasta información sobre sus contactos
con grupos extremistas en virtud de una
votación unánime el comité selecto
emitió una citación al expresidente
Donald Trump para que brinde testimonio
y registros relevantes para la
investigación del comité selecto sobre
el ataque del 6 de enero al Capitolio de
los Estados Unidos y sus causas Trump
deberá presentarse al Capitolio en
persona o en videoconferencia a partir
del 14 de noviembre y de ser necesario
durante varios días el comité también
señaló que los documentos deben ser
presentados antes del 4 de noviembre y
hasta el momento no está claro si el ex
mandatario aceptará la citación paralelo
a la orden de citación Steve banon uno
de los antiguos profesores del ex
presidente fue sentenciado a cuatro
meses de prisión y Apagar 6.500 dólares
por no acudir a declarar sobre el mismo
caso ante el comité
tendremos un proceso de apelación
vigoroso para esta decisión tenga un
gran equipo legal y habrá múltiples
áreas de apelación Pero como dice ese
letrero a la derecha ahí podemos tener
el letrero de Voto el 8 de noviembre van
a tener un juicio sobre el régimen
ilegítimo de biden
habrá que ver si estos nuevos hechos
influirán en los resultados de las
elecciones de medio término en las
cuales los estadounidenses decidirán si
mantienen en El poder del Congreso a los
demócratas o si los republicanos podrán
tener más protagonismo